and then you'll get a bunch of other
things that like aren't even
possible or you don't even think about
using a phone or pc for today like
fitness right so i mean i know
you're um
we were talking before about how you're
you're into running and like i'm really
into you know a lot of things around
fitness as well um you know different
things in different places i got really
into hydrofoiling recently and nice um
and i i saw video yeah and surfing and
um
and i used to fence competitively i like
run so and you were saying that you were
thinking about trying different martial
arts and i tried to trick you and
convince you into doing uh brazilian
jiu-jitsu or you actually mentioned that
that was one you're curious about and
is that a trick yeah i don't know
we're in the metaverse now yeah i think
i mean i took that seriously i thought
that that was a that was a real uh
uh
suggestion that would be an amazing
chance if we ever step on the mat
together and just like roll around i'll
show you some moves well give me a year
to train and and then and then like rock
you know you've seen rocky iv where the
russian faces off the america i'm the
russian in this picture and then you
you're the rocky the underdog that gets
to to win the idea of me as rocky and
like fighting is um if he dies he dies
i mean
you